hey guys welcome to Cydonia Hills part 7
which is quite an interesting video
actually I think since I got more work
done than I expected beforehand so
there's quite a bit of stuff in this
episode which is also a little bit of a
problem since I'm not really sure what
I'm gonna have to do the next episode it
will either become extremely short or
extremely long and messy so we'll see
about that but that's something to worry
about in the future but in this video
I'll lay down most of what is going to
be the core of the theming of the
Japanese area lots of buildings lots of
paths work also foliage and gardening
and all sorts of decorations so yeah
that's what I want to get into here
another basic build up of the Japanese
area almost sort of mirrors the build up
of the Alpine area it has this sort of
very large winding plaza like path in
the middle of it where I wanted to place
all of the biggest buildings and
attractions on the side of it so also
wanted to add this quick slide over here
and on the side of that as well I wanted
to add all sorts of buildings which is
what most of this area is gonna be made
out of and what most of this video is
also going to be made out of so um I
just wanted to quickly lay down those
paths so I had kind of an idea of where
and how I wanted to build the buildings
and know for sure that they would kind
of work out which is pretty nice way to
plan buildings out though in hindsight I
probably should have just used crown
pins instead of paths because guests
started walking in places where I didn't
really want them but yeah it's the
planning worked out in the end so what I
wanted to do here with the buildings is
make some Japanese town houses I think
the correct Japanese name for it is a
machiya but somewhere some Japanese
person probably wants to kill me now for
that pronunciation so I'll just call
them Japanese town houses from now on
but the other thing that I wanted to get
into this area mostly and make most of
the scenery out of they're not the most
they're not like the first thing that
most people think about when you think
of Japanese architecture they're not
really the most representative thing in
that sense like you'd be more inclined
to think of big temple buildings and
pagodas and things like that
but if you're going into the
and the more classical side of Japan
that still Neffs they are what you're
going to see most around cities and
villages and if that's why I've wanted
to use these townhouses to get most of
the buildings in in here and I was a
little bit worried about this at first
because I wasn't really sure how to
exactly tackle these buildings what
makes them kind of tough to work with is
that they're very narrow houses they're
not that big they're much like other
townhouses in the world in a sense that
they're often very narrow because Texas
used to be paid by how much of the
street you're occupying so a narrow
house just means that you need to pay
less tax and in that sense that became
sort of very narrow houses with a small
front with a small roof sticking out and
a few decorations on the front but not
that much and most of what makes them so
distinctly Japanese is that typical in
Japanese town how its build up and also
the details that you have in there but
the details are obviously something that
are hard to get into in poetics so there
was a lot of shuffling with these roofs
to actually make sure that they kind of
look like some Japanese town houses
basic build up is just simple gable roof
on the top with one roof on the front
sticking out and as for the backs of
these buildings I wasn't really too
worried about that you would see them in
real life being longer than these
buildings are but for the sake of this
being a theme park and not really having
any more space the front and how these
buildings connect to the past is what I
was most concerned with and what most of
my tension was going to yeah that's
basically shuffling with the roofs in a
sense that I had to use the simple gable
roofs that the game gives you to get the
basic roof shape in the flat roof size
actually work quite nicely to not only
make the roofs hang over the grid a
little bit but also give them that very
distinctly Japanese sort of curve into
the roof which townhouses don't actually
usually have but it does help to sort of
give this entire area a bit of a
Japanese theme park five so I'm quite
happy with that as well and some of the
details include just
make pretend windows in all of the
buildings by just putting some pillows
together it is kind of a shame that the
base game doesn't have any windows that
aren't actually transparent yet because
windows that you can just block over an
existing wall even though they aren't
technically windows are quite nice and
easy to use for games like this but yeah
since there is a lack of them at the
moment I just figured it would be nice
to use pillars instead which do kind of
have that Japanese paper screen window
look to them so that worked out quite
nicely and for all of the buildings I'm
just putting some random details
together to make something that looks
like a door pretty much which is never
actually a door and often just made out
of gravestones or pipes but I'm quite
happy with how those turned out as well
so as you can notice at this point
probably is that most of these buildings
do follow this same blueprints template
idea of what itano's looks like it's
just one big part that sticks out and
the lower roof that connects it to the
path which overhangs a bit maybe has
some posts that support it's just over
the pot as well though I did want to
watch out with that a little bit because
I don't want to go right into the middle
of the pots because then obviously
you'll end up with people walking
straight through posts and things like
that and yeah that's a little bit
problematic so I didn't want to avoid
that now in the middle of this here I
just had a bit of foliage and the reason
that I want to fill in all of these
areas quite densely is not just because
this is in the end of Clarke in a sort
of Foresti setting I wouldn't normally
say that you should fill up every single
part of the park with just trees it can
actually be really nice to have some
open areas as well but in this case I
also really needed it to give a bit of a
transition between these these areas
because the Japanese area is quite close
to the other areas in the park the only
thing that really divides them could be
the foliage because there isn't any kind
of gates or anything not really you know
puts up a wall between these areas and
make sure that you don't see the other
area
from another area if that makes any
sense so um yeah I wanted to use my
foliage as a bit of a smokescreen to
prevent being able to look at the other
areas while you're in the alpine area or
something like that and I wanted to
sprinkle a few colored trees on top just
to give it that slight Japanese look
without adding any ridiculous foliage or
cherry trees because that's sadly
impossible and ended up with some grass
on the bottom again just to give it that
extra ground foliage detail which is
probably gonna be very bad for the
performance of this park though then
again it might also be used for
performance testing I don't know it's
probably a pretty good thing to add
cross to this anyway
I do always like to cluster it around in
like small clusters to kind of give you
the idea that there's a lot of grass on
the ground instead of just leaving them
ovary sparse and with just about the
same distance from each other or it just
doesn't give as much of a dense look
with the same amount of grass sprites
and I just kind of like clustering
ground foliage quite a bit it is a bit
of Japanese thing as well but Japanese
gardening is something which I'll hardly
get into and I'll only do so a little
bit in the next episode I won't really
go into any foliage magic in this
episode quite yet now I still had a
little bit of space left over here and
it isn't quite enough to actually get a
proper town house in especially with the
monorail and the coaster and the pagoda
on all sides it is quite a very crammed
space but it's one little dead-end
corner where I didn't really want to
keep it empty because it is quite
central to this area and so I wanted to
just add a very small stall to it almost
in a roller coaster tycoon one kind of
store idea except it's two tiles instead
of one and I think that's a store which
serves a hot chocolate so I may want to
look at that because that's not the most
theme related thing it's kind of weird
to have a hot chocolate store in a
Japanese section of a park no matter how
popular hot chocolate might be in Japan
I'm not sure about that but um yeah
that's just a quick little store to give
it some sort of building and give you
some sort of thing that you can actually
do on that Plaza because if I actually
want to keep people on that central
plaza and actually have something to
attract guests I've got to actually have
some functional stalls just a nice way
to add some extra atmosphere to the
plaza
now skipping this boring bit of doing
foliage here and back to making some
buildings which are think I'm going to
be very similar to the buildings which
I've built before in this episode just
with a little bit more practice so a
little bit quicker I suppose and maybe a
bit better too though you be the judge
but that's they are mostly just similar
and following the same general formula
that I followed earlier on the only
thing that I could really say to keep in
mind about this though is that I
definitely filled up some spaces on
these buildings which in hindsight and
didn't have to because they are
connected buildings so these windows and
pillars on the side and everything there
isn't really exactly necessary in real
life these buildings wouldn't always be
like right next to each other and like
just a very small space between them but
obviously this game just works on one
four grid four walls so they had to be
right next to each other which there
were a cup of compromises which I wanted
to make for that as well because just to
make it look like they are almost like
1/2 a meter away from each other wanted
to give them slightly different heights
on the roofs to make sure that the roofs
don't directly connect which does help
quite a bit to at least give them a very
slight sort of offset look to them even
though they are exactly in the same grid
and exactly in the same placement so the
first house is pretty much finished and
it's quite a simple house nearly exactly
the same to the ones that I've made
before now for this building I wanted to
experiment a bit not going completely
wild with it but it's a bit solo and it
actually has some for some pretty poor
Shoji screens which I am not sure if
they're actually in the right placement
but they're basically they're sliding
paper walls that you see around Japanese
buildings instead of just a very small
paper windows that I made
or and I'm giving this building some
extra Heights to make sure that it's
offset both from the building that I
made just before this one and the
building that I'm gonna make on the
corner just to have all sorts of
different sizes and Heights for all of
the buildings on this string of facades
which I believe is the biggest string of
facades in this entire section of the
park now aside from that little quirk of
the heights and the pace this building
is the same as the building on the right
again
though the roof is also refer reversed
on this one
now the Kohler building is quite a bit
different a bit more similar to the
corner building which I made earlier in
this episode but it also uses a slightly
different color scheme not 100% sure yet
how much I like it but there were going
to be like a lot of dark gray brownish
tones in many of the buildings so far so
I wanted to get a building which would
look like it would be a little bit more
new and new bit lighter in color and
play with some different kind of window
textures here so that's in the end turn
out to be a building which I am not
actually sure what kind of shop that is
yeah actually no idea but um you could
actually see me placing the roofs for
many places for many times during these
videos on all of the buildings that I
make which isn't the fastest thing but I
always think that the best way to kind
of tell what a building is going to look
like especially compared to what's
around it is to just quickly built the
roof because it really gives away the
general shape of the building and how
large it's gonna be it's almost kind of
like a math study to see yeah what the
building is going to look like finally
shape wise and that's why I place a lot
of these proofs and remove them later on
it is to be very honest I don't really
like having the roofs in there so you
because yeah if you have the roofs in
there you can't really look at what's
underneath them or behind them so they
are kind of annoying I just kind of
place them to get an idea what the shape
of the building is going to be then
remove them then build the rest of the
building without any roofs blocking my
view and finally put in the roofs and
all sorts of accents and details that
can get into it in the end that's how I
usually like to do things it might not
be the very fastest way but it is
usually a good way to know exactly the
way your building is going to look in
the game without having to build the
complete building first and I think in
the end it might save you time over
having to tweak the shape of a building
afterwards because nothing is really
worse than building a building first
doing all of the details and everything
and only at that point realizing that
your roof should have been like one tile
lower or moved to the right a little bit
less so yeah I always like to get made
sure that I have the shape before I
actually get into all of the details now
with all those buildings done it's time
to spruce up the first pieces yeah it's
time to add some extra decoration by
adding all of the foliage in we're
pretty much since this is quite a dense
area with lots of buildings in parts I
did want to spruce it up quite densely
and at many trees around there wherever
I could to at least still keep quite a
forest II look even though it is such a
dense area now Hiro was planning ahead a
little bit though you'll see more of
this area in the next video there won't
be a temple and the ferris wheel around
here kind of gonna be like a very small
solid Japanese Bulevar except the
Italian Boulevard was pretty much next
to a large lake with a log flume and a
pretty good view and this is just next
to a small Creek but I figured it would
fit in quite nicely and have some good
interaction with the coaster and also be
a pretty good base to add some extra
decoration around it so that's why I
ended up going for that and just to get
rid of that sort of legacy look of the
enterprise with all of the legacy fences
and posts I wanted to cover that up a
little bit as well I'm actually like one
of the things that I am so happy about
in alpha 3 because this is actually the
first alpha 3 video is the fact that
when you place a fence it just instantly
replaces whatever fence was on its place
so in the past if you'd build a fence
over an already existing automatically
placed fence of an attraction or over
raised path you'd have double fences but
fences actually replaced each other now
which is a really cool feature
and quite handy if you wanna you know
customize things to whatever theme or
look you're going for now at the back of
this I want to have some foliage because
this is also going to be another
transition area into what is most likely
going to actually end up being a Western
area I don't talk about it too much
because it is quite far into the future
but in real life I have to start work on
that area quite soon and I hope to
actually start work on a western area
should hopefully fit in quite nice with
the sort of geographical theme of this
park with having a Roman and Alpine in a
Japanese section so that's something
you'll see in the future and I at least
want to make sure that it could connect
from the Japanese area and the Alpine
area in some ways so there was a bit of
preparation for that and the rest of
this is pretty much the path elements
which I always end up doing lost but not
very least because it does have quite a
big influence on how the area looks and
yeah I've really really needed to
actually add some path elements and
benches some lights and little pins to
decorate this make it look a little bit
more alive and less empty so there's
just a lot of placing lamps and benches
little bins here with no exact kind of
planning or idea other than it just has
to look good that's pretty much
everything that went for here anyway
that's it's for this video so thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
guys next time in which I'll take you on
a trip to build a Japanese temple and a
ferris wheel and do all sorts of
decorations across the entire park that
we're adding in alpha-3 and in offer to
you as well actually so hope to see you
guys then